el ataque fue súbito un avión militar
ruso acaba de ser destruido en el puerto
de dearyansk controlado por el ejército
ruso otras dos naves huyen del incendio
els fue la primera nave de combate rusa
en ingresar al puerto descargaba
material militar en las costas del mar
de apenas tres días es tu oficial de la
marina rusa se alegraba por su presencia
la llegada de esta gran nave al puerto
de verdians es un acontecimiento mayor
abrió oportunidades para nuestra flota
un breve es importante para el ejército
ruso que también enfrenta problemas
logísticos fallos revelados en
comunicaciones no encriptadas que
contienen conversaciones entre soldados
rusos y que fueron interceptadas por el
ejército ucraniano necesidad urgente de
combustible necesidad urgente de
combustible los vehículos están parados
en la carretera urgente peticiones de
combustible agua y comida pero también
de material militar básico
es un verdadero desastre aquí
aguanten
Incluso en checheniano era tan
complicado nuestros propios aviones nos
bombardean te imaginas soldados rusos en
territorio enemigo Generalmente
abandonados a su propia suerte no pueden
apoyarse sobre la población para
encontrar comida no tienen carpas para
dormir hasta la mitad de su Batallón ha
sido destruido en los combates los rusos
Simplemente no tienen refuerzos y cada
día que pasa son menos numerosos y la
moral se derrumbaba
498 soldados han muerto desde el
principio de la guerra serían más de
15.000 según el ejército ucra